8h30 dans ce paisible quartier du nord
de Laval un autobus de la ville enfonce
les murs de la garderie éducative
Sainte-Rose 80 enfants ils passent
habituellement leur journée un appel est
aussi au fait au 91 les parents sur
place sont sous le choc j'étais la
première une des premières à t'appeler
dans mon mari était en train de laisser
notre enfant puis c'est arrivé devant
ses yeux la classe qui est affectée
c'est la classe des papillons qui est
vraiment la classe des plus vieux il y a
des enfants qui ont été percutés là il y
en a un qui a été sorti en dessous de
l'autobus que je suis actrice c'était le
chaos les enfants ils sont là parce
qu'ils ne comprennent pas ce qui se
passe et il y a des enfants blessés mais
on sait pas
avant l'arrivée des secours on sera vite
compte que quelque chose cloche avec le
chauffeur le conjoint de Nathalie fait
partie des parents qui l'empêche de fuir
parce que vous pouvez nous dire ce que
vous avez fait pour aider justement
les images témoignent de la force de
l'impact c'est un cauchemar je n'arrive
pas c'est horrible c'est horrible à midi
qui habite la maison voisine est tout de
suite à couru vers la garderie on a
essayé de maîtriser le chauffeur quoi
il a ouvert la porte il a retiré tous
ses vêtements il était totalement nu on
n'a pas compris pourquoi il a fait ça on
a plongé sur lui on a essayé de
maîtriser il crier il n'arrête pas de
créer il était dans un autre monde
carrément il estime que l'autobus
roulait à 30 ou 40 km/h au moment de
l'impact comme la garderie est située au
fond d'un stationnement dans un
rond-point l'hypothèse d'un acte
délibéré et rapidement soulevé voilà
j'ai même pris une photo à 83 je suis le
premier
il est très autobus
de France c'est délibérément garderie
bien aligné bien droite c'est le
chauffeur est arrêté par les policiers
et un large périmètre de sécurité est
aussitôt établi dans leur qui suit les
parents alertés à court pour venir
chercher leurs enfants l'attention est
grande
certains soulagés repartent avec leur
tout petit d'autres ne les trouvent pas
et attendent d'avoir des nouvelles le
pire cauchemar à 10h30 la police fait
son premier point de presse oui on a
malheureusement le des personnes qui ont
été blessées gravement et les parents
être rencontrés c'est des jeunes enfants
donc comprendrez que l'information va
rentrer mais plus tard
à Québec l'Assemblée nationale observe
un moment de silence le drame secoue la
classe politique comme père de famille
j'étais branlé et puis je trouve ça
je peux comprendre
l'angoisse qui vivent actuellement
Paul saint-pierre-plamondon ne trouve
pas les mots
au même moment le maire de Laval arrive
sur les lieux on me dit que le chauffeur
était à l'emploi de la STL depuis une
dizaine d'années mais qui avait pas de
dossiers particuliers ou d'incident
particulier je suis surtout ici pour
démontrer mon appui aux familles c'est
un acte assez tragique évidemment il y a
plein de parents en ce moment qui se
demandent est-ce que mon enfant est
touché on a réussi à sortir un petit
enfant qui n'est pas trop blessé il y
avait une petite blessure à la dernière
minute on a entendu une voix une voix
d'une fille il était en dessous de la de
des murs et là les pompiers ils n'ont
demandé de sortir carrément parce que
c'est eux qui vont intervenir sur
l'heure du midi les appréhensions se
confirment d'abord à 11h40 par urgence
santé ce que je peux vous dire à cette
étape si c'est que 12 personnes ont été
évaluées les 8 personnes ont été
transportées avec deux blessures
sérieuses dans les différents centres
hospitaliers de la région de Montréal et
dans la région de Laval puis une
demi-heure plus tard par la police
malheureusement il y a deux décès deux
jeunes enfants qui sont procéder
l'identification du suspect est ensuite
rendu public il y a un homme de 51 ans
un conducteur de la STL qui a été arrêté
pour congé de dangereuse et homicide
Pierre ni saint Amand a comparer de son
lit d'hôpital il fait face à neuf chefs
d'accusation dont deux pour meurtre au
premier degré on ignore encore pourquoi
il a commis ce geste
à comparaître ce que questionner le jeu
c'est que le personnel hospitalier
voulait que Monsieur Saint-Amand a une
évaluation psychiatrique par contre
c'était au niveau de la dangerosité de
Monsieur ils n'ont pas de son attitude
début d'après-midi trois ministres se
rendent sur place avec le maire et la
police l'événement ce matin est une est
une est une tragédie d'une infinie
tristesse on est ici pour supporter
supporter les familles et au nom du
gouvernement veut leur dire qu'on nous
serons présents les premiers
intervenants sont sous le choc nous leur
offrons actuellement du soutien
psychologique autant au niveau du SPL de
service d'incendie journée pénible aussi
dans les hôpitaux à Sainte Justine deux
garçons et deux filles ont été traitées
mais leur vie n'est pas mise en jeu au
moment où on vous parle nous sommes dans
un premier 24 heures bien entendu
l'évolution est difficile à prévoir
toujours chez des enfants donc sont en
investigation donc autant en plan
cérébral qu'au plan abdominal donc
vraiment c'est un polytraumatisme une
des victimes serait morte sur place à la
garderie l'autre à la Cité de la santé
de Laval et on a reçu trois trois
patients il y en a deux qui demeurent
sous observation et une victime qui
malheureusement est décédée malgré les
manœuvres de réanimation la Sûreté du
Québec c'est joint est à l'enquête qui
se poursuit c'est des enfants là c'est
toujours pourquoi la question pourquoi
il y a pas de réponse ce soir c'est
toute la province qui est en deuil